[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous
heureux de vous retrouver pour une
nouvelle semaine de sens public votre
rendez-vous quotidien de débat et de
reportage sur public c'est la 90 minutes
pour donner du sens à l'actualité vous
proposez des clés de compréhension des
crises que nous traversons et justement
c'est par l'inflation que nous ouvrons
cette émission là haute générale en
France et de 5,7% mais pour
l'alimentation c'est bien pire avec une
flambée le près de 16% sur un an peut-on
espérer un retour à la normale après
l'été la France était le mieux lotique
ses voisins européens comment casser
l'inflation on décortique le phénomène
on cherche des solutions aussi avec nos
invités experts dans une minute la
défense du pouvoir d'achat c'est
notamment sur ce combat que Marine Le
Pen construit sa popularité dans notre
second débat on va analyser sa stratégie
de sobriété parlementaire et de quasi
silence dans le débat sur les retraites
est-elle vraiment payante une victoire
de Marine Le Pen en 2027 est-elle de
moins en moins improbable
en nous donnant le groupe d'opposition
le
plus c'est nous ont clairement désigné
comme le la force d'alternance pour le
dire clairement quand ça ne sera plus
Emmanuel Macron ce sera nous
comment le RN veut-il construire sa
stratégie sa marge vers le pouvoir
quelles sont les fondements
sociologiques du vote Le Pen réponse
dans trois quarts d'heure mais d'abord
le constat des hausses de prix en France
avec Mathias
céréales pâtes produits laitiers ou
s'arrêtera la spirale inflationniste qui
frappe deux plein fouet le secteur
alimentaire interrogé par des lecteurs
du journal Le Parisien Emmanuel Macron
fait un constat implacable je vais être
honnête les prix alimentaires ça va être
dur jusqu'à la fin de l'été avec
pratiquement 16% d'augmentation
l'alimentaire tire vers le haut
l'inflation globale à 5,7% sur un an la
semaine dernière le gouverneur de la
Banque de France prenait l'engagement
qu'en 2024 l'inflation serait à 2%, une
promesse difficile à tenir selon
certains économistes dans nos prévisions
nous on finit plutôt à 3% à la fin 2024
mais ça veut dire qu'on commence quand
même à le reflux de l'inflation est
plutôt à partir de 24 donc 2023 il a des
difficile en terme d'inflation il faut
pas s'attendre à un retournement en tout
cas dans dans les mois à venir et puis
une fois de plus passer un pic
d'inflation on a une inflation qui est
moins élevée ça veut pas dire que les
prix baisses c'est juste que
les prix augmentent ma vie dans
l'opposition certains cri à l'inaction
gouvernementale notamment dans le
secteur de l'énergie Emmanuel Macron
parle de l'inflation sans rien faire et
bien nous nous disons que le marché de
l'électricité européen est responsable
et que c'est une des pistes que nous
devons explorer du côté de l'exécutif
Bruno Le Maire a appelé les industriels
dont les marges ont augmenté a baissé
leur prix Emmanuel Macron pour sa part
renvoie la balle aux employeurs en
plaidant pour une augmentation des
salaires
possibilité territoriale et pour ce
premier débat j'accueille deniferon
bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes économiste
directeur général de Rex et code de
Pascal et belle bonsoir bienvenue aussi
vous êtes économiste spécialisé en
anticipation du comportement des
consommateurs directrices associés chez
c-ways Richard Verly bonsoir bonsoir
bienvenue à vous correspondants pour le
média Suisse Blic et Guillaume d'arrêt
bonsoiriste politique alors on les a vu
mais je rappelle quand même c'est ces
chiffres en mars c'est une inflation de
5,7% sur un an en France et pour
l'alimentation et c'est certainement
cette hausse des prix qui est la plus
ressentie par les Français que nous
ressentons le plus
15,9% en mars par rapport à l'année
dernière de différents peut-être
commencé par expliquer les raisons
rappelées d'où ça vient le point de
départ si on remonte un peu c'est la
crise covid oui sans remonter jusqu'au
paléolithique on peut commencer par la
crise covid ou plutôt la sortie de la
crise covid en fait on on est arrivé à
un moment où il y a eu un écart très
important entre le niveau de la demande
qui en fait a été préservé
rappelons-nous pendant la période covid
l'activité s'est arrêtée mais pas la
distribution de revenus les revenus ont
été versés il y avait de l'activité
partielle donc la capacité à dépenser a
été préservée mais en sortie du covid la
capacité d'offre elle n'était pas
forcément au rendez-vous la capacité
d'offre donc le fait de pouvoir délivrer
des produits en temps et en heure et
donc c'est installé un déséquilibre
entre l'offre et la demande qui a été à
l'origine d'un certain nombre de
pénuries que l'on a vu parler en de
nombreux points et qui progressivement
ces cristallisé dans une accélération
des prix en plus c'était amplifié parce
que on n'était pas complètement sûr que
l'activité elle est vraiment redémarrée
en 2021 donc une politique monétaire
très dynamique une politique budgétaire
très soutenue qui en fait accentué
encore ce décalage entre l'offre et la
demande et donc à favoriser la formation
de pénurie et là-dessus survient le choc
en Ukraine mais en fait le choquant en
Ukraine agit un peu comme un détonateur
si vous voulez sur une situation qui
était déjà potentiellement
donc il y a eu le tournesol
souvenez-vous aussi ça ça venait quand
même du Canada hein c'est-à-dire que on
s'est rendu compte que sur la moutarde
sur le tournesol on en produisait pas
suffisamment en Europe donc il y avait
cette tension sur l'alimentaire elles
sont paliers finalement au covid en
dehors des prix sur le transport le prix
sur l'emballage le prix du carton mais
ça pèse pas
significativement sur les produits
agricoles et donc il y a les
spéculateurs on y reviendra on y pense à
quoi il y a vraiment le climat c'est à
dire que là en ce moment les plus forte
hausses les légumes on en produit en
France et c'est bien parce que il a fait
très très sec et pas assez d'eau dans
les productions de Bretagne je voudrais
vous donner un autre chiffre qui m'a
frappé en préparant cette cette émission
c'est c'est la hausse des vols à
l'étalage plus 14,7% en 2022 chiffre du
ministère de l'Intérieur qui sont
certainement
sous-estimés ou sous-évalé parce qu'il y
a beaucoup de de ces vols de nourriture
notamment qui se règle à l'amiable dans
les magasins qui sont jamais déclarés à
la police Richard Verly je ça pose la
question des conséquences sociétale
d'une situation comme celle-là c'est et
je trouve que c'est aussi important de
le dire dès le début de ce débat sur une
sorte de déclassement pour pour une
partie de la population ou d'un
sentiment de déclassement pour une
partie de la population oui j'ai regardé
la situation dans les différents pays
européens et notamment dans les pays
voisins de la France au fond alors ils
n'ont pas tous le même niveau
d'inflation et on peut dire que la
France a plutôt bien réussi à contenir
son niveau d'inflation le mauvais
exemple serait par exemple le
Royaume-Uni ou l'inflation a dépassé
même approché les 11%. mais par contre
le phénomène commun à tous ces pays
c'est que c'est anxiogène l'inflation
voilà ça génère de l'anxiété ça génère
de l'angoisse d'abord parce qu'on
commence à intérioriser l'idée qu'on
aura peut-être plus les moyens d'acheter
même si c'est pas le cas aujourd'hui ça
sera peut-être le cas demain il y a tout
de suite la peur aussi de l'immobilier
on va perdre sur un certain nombre de de
valeurs patrimoniales qui étaient en
quelque sorte le socle sur lequel on
était en pyé et au fond c'est ça la
réalité d'aujourd'hui c'est qu'il y a
l'effet économique direct de l'inflation
il l'effet anxiogène qui va amener à des
dépenses ou simplement à consommer
autrement en France vous le savez
aujourd'hui la marque les marques
préférées des Français c'est comme par
hasard des marques discount aussi bien
dans l'alimentaire que dans le non
alimentaire
en tête on va dire c'était Decathlon
Leroy Merlin qui a créé toujours en tête
qui se partagait et puis là il y a une
main qui s'appelle action je crois c'est
ça qui est arrivé numéro 1 quoi moi je
recommande il y a d'autres marques de
discours je recommande à tout le monde
sans leur faire de publicité mais par
simple curiosité d'aller dans ces
nouveaux supermarchés action 800
établissements en France quand même ils
ont doublé en deux ans et là vous voyez
que les gens ont l'air quand même envie
de consommer mais ils ont envie de
consommer moins cher et ils vont dans
ces établissements et là c'est très
intéressant parce que quand vous parlez
ce que j'ai fait avec des consommateurs
vous voyez qu'ils ont intériorisé le
fait que de toute manière ils n'auront
plus les moyens de payer des biens de
consommation dans d'autres supermarchés
que cela alors il y a aussi l'idole
tiens j'essaie de trouver une deuxième
marque pour encaisser pour en citer une
seule aussi parce que de plus en plus on
voit le camion tout transport sur les
autoroutes et c'est une marque qu'on a
vu beaucoup apparaître alors qu'on la
voyait beaucoup moins on n'a pas
d'action chez Action on va être très
clair sur ces prix de l'alimentaire et
ce qui nous a d'ailleurs donné envie je
vais très clair on est toujours sur le
plus transport possible avec vous de
d'organiser ce débat aujourd'hui c'est
cette déclaration du Président de la
République faço lecteur du de nos
confrères du Parisien Aujourd'hui en
France interview réalisé vendredi
diffusée ce matin voilà ce qu'il dit
Emmanuel Macron je vais être honnête les
prix de l'alimentaire ça va être dur
jusqu'à la fin de l'été sur quoi ça ça
se base cet échéance de différents
est-ce qu'on peut espérer effectivement
une amélioration à la rentrée alors sur
deux choses parce qu'effectivement on a
parlé de l'Ukraine l'Ukraine ça fait
déjà un an et pourquoi est-ce qu'on a
les prix de l'alimentaire maintenant qui
qui flamme parce que en fait il y a
toujours des effets de retard il y a des
effets de délai c'est-à-dire qu'entre le
moment vous allez avoir une flambée sur
les prix de marché prix du marché du blé
pour quelques raisons que ce soit des
effets des effets de spéculation
éventuels mais il y a aussi des
déséquilibres importants vous allez
avoir en gros entre 6 mois entre le
moment où vous avez la tomber des prix
sur les marchés mondiaux et la hausse
des prix du producteur à la hausse du
prix de sortie d'usine et vous allez
encore avoir trois mois entre la hausse
du prix du producteur et l'arrivée dans
l'état c'est ce sont des ordres de
grandeur que je vous donne là c'est pas
une régularité mais c'est la manière
dont on peut le mesurer et pourquoi
est-ce que ça va être dur jusqu'à l'été
parce que au mois de mars ont été
conclus les négociations entre
distributeurs et industriels qui
promettent une hausse de l'ordre de 10%
qui va être perlé qui va être répandu au
cours des trois mois avril mais ou
supplémentaire de 10% sur des produits
qui ont déjà augmenté de 16% sur un an
évidemment oui parce qu'effectivement
l'indicateur auquel vous faites
référence s'applique au mois de mars
donc ce sont les hausses à venir sont de
l'ordre de 10% jusqu'au mois de juin et
après bon tout dépendra de on a quand
même eu le reflux des prix des prix sur
les marchés donc à un moment ou un autre
il y aura un mouvement de sens inverse
qui passe sur les marchés internationaux
alors justement ça ça m'amène à la
question j'allais vous poser parce
qu'elle est belle qui est
j'assume mon côté bossien peut-être
qu'elle va oublier est-ce qu'on peut
revenir au prix d'avant vous voyez ce
que je veux dire et est-ce que ça prend
longtemps parce que c'est une question
moi quand je discute avec des amis de de
toute la sociale c'est la question ok
mais la baguette elle est montée atténue
est-ce qu'elle reviendra un jour à son à
son prix d'avant alors c'est vraiment le
je pense le paradoxe un petit peu en
France et que vu les cycles de
négociation vu finalement la complexité
du système pour de formation des prix
sur l'alimentation on sent qu'on
reviendra pas en arrière alors que sur
la voiture les prix des voitures sont en
train de baisser alors que finalement il
y a tout un tas de postes sur lesquels
on voit un reflux puisqu'on est qu'à
5,7% d'inflation aujourd'hui donc c'est
là que c'est là qu'on voit que c'est
compliqué parce qu'en effet le prix du
blé il a presque été divisé par deux
depuis trois quatre mois donc on se dit
pourquoi on n'arrive pas à répercuter
ces prix là je pense que sur
l'alimentaire on a quand même ces
questions de récolte qui sont plus
faibles c'est-à-dire que le riz en a eu
des inondations Pakistan donc forcément
les prix augmentent aujourd'hui et donc
c'est bien parce que on va avoir en tous
les cas des difficultés sur les matières
premières agricoles à l'avenir c'est
évident le changement climatique va
faire que on aura tout le temps des
sécheresses qu'on va avoir cet été en
France on aura des sécheresses ailleurs
et donc des inondations dans d'autres
endroits donc on aura finalement
toujours c'est peut-être pour ça
qu'Emmanuel Macron prévient un petit peu
tous les consommateurs c'est que sur
l'alimentation n'est pas prêt d'avoir
des baisses sur les matières premières
agricoles même si l'un on sent qu'il y a
quand même des acteurs économiques qui
veulent faire comme sur la voiture
d'ailleurs gagner des marges en plus
parce qu'ils ont eu un renier sur leur
marge l'année dernière Richard werley
comme vous êtes là en fait souvent un
zoom sur la Suisse parce que la Suisse
c'est où salaire comparé à la France et
moins inquiète face à cette inflation
non justement l'anxiété la même alors il
y a eu une inflation qui est à peu près
de 4% donc l'inflation elle est arrivée
en Suisse comme ailleurs bien évidemment
la référence et qu'il n'y a pas tous les
dispositifs d'aide publique par exemple
le bouclier énergétique donc les
consommateurs les ménages ont subi un
choc inflationniste plus important
qu'ils ont encaissé grâce à des
rémunérations plus élevées vous l'avez
dit et combien par exemple sur l'énergie
par rapport à peu près je crois que
c'est 20 %. 20 %. donc il y a eu il y a
eu un choc assez similaire par contre là
où c'est très intéressant c'est que la
Suisse n'étant pas membre de l'Union
européenne et bien ce qu'on a entendu
tout à l'heure de Manon Aubry à savoir
c'est la faute du marché européen de
l'électricité se déballe n'a pas lieu
parce que finalement le raisonnement en
Suisse il reste encore très national
n'oublions quand même pas une chose
quand on parle d'inflation c'est que ça
profite à certaines catégories c'est
aussi le lobby des paysans par exemple
et bien en ce moment il profite de cette
inflation donc ça génère aussi de la
richesse pour une certaine catégorie de
population et ça je crois qu'il faut
quand même le rappeler et puis un
élément
si on regarde la géopolitique de
l'inflation n'oublions pas qu'il y a
aujourd'hui un combat stratégique très
fort qui joue notamment sur les
États-Unis et la Chine et ce n'est pas
dans l'intérêt des États-Unis qui sont
une puissance à la fois industrielle et
agricole de faire baisser les prix c'est
pas du tout dans leur intérêt ils ont
intérêt à maintenir des prix élevés pour
l'énergie pour les produits industriels
et pour les produits agricoles puisqu'on
parlait des des salaires un mot
là-dessus de différents est-ce que la
hausse des salaires parce qu'il y a des
négociations sur les hausses de salaire
en France mais partout en Europe il y a
eu un accord en Allemagne qui a été
signé notamment pour les les
fonctionnaires avec une menace de grève
générale qui a été évitée après je ne
sais plus quoi trois ou quatrièmement de
négociation bref est-ce que on parle de
spirale parfois est-ce que la hausse des
salaires alimentent l'inflation alors il
alimente une inflation qui change un peu
de nature alors déjà quelle est la rosée
salaire tout dépend de ce que l'on met
dans l'ensemble des salaires si on prend
le salaire stricto sensu c'est à dire
celui qui est frappé de cotisations
sociales on est sur une progression de
4% à la fin de l'année 2022 par rapport
à la fin 2021 donc moins que l'inflation
mais en revanche si la prime pour le
partage de la valeur qui est une prime
qui est exonérée de cotisations si on
intègre cette prime alors on est sur une
progression de 5,8%. donc grosso modo
l'évolution de l'inflation mais vous
voyez qu'on est passé par des mécanismes
qui sortent du salariat qui passe par
quelque chose qui est de la prérogative
de l'employeur et qui surtout n'est pas
maintenu quand vous avez une
augmentation de salaire cet irréversible
vous n'avez pas de retour en arrière sur
une prime vous pouvez avoir un retour en
arrière qui intervient donc pour
l'instant on est sur une progression
salariale qui compense une question qui
va être importante c'est est-ce qu'on va
avoir en 2023 non pas une une un
assemblage hausse de salaire et de prime
ou si cette augmentation de la prime va
en réalité se retrouver dans l'évolution
des salaires et dans le mouvement des
négociations qui se fait actuellement
notamment des négociations au niveau des
branches au niveau des entreprises on a
une progression de salariale qui disait
a priori un peu plus forte en 2023 que
celle qui est intervenue l'année
dernière alors on a commencé à le faire
mais on va détailler le comparatif
européen avec Alexandre tout ça qui va
rejoindre tout de suite sur ce plateau
bonsoir Alexandre bienvenue à vous
heureux de vous retrouver sur le plateau
de de Sonic alors comment la France se
situe par rapport à ses voisins
européens et bien Bruno Le Maire ne
cesse de le répéter à ces derniers mois
la France est l'un des pays européens
qui est le moins impacté par la hausse
des prix alors c'est aussi un argument
du gouvernement pour justifier les
mesures mises en œuvre sur ce sujet mais
effectivement la France est bien classée
dans ce domaine alors ce n'est pas quand
même et bien le champion d'Europe de la
lutte anti-inflation si on prend le
classement de l'agence eurostatt sur le
taux d'inflation annuel en février
dernier et bien la France était en 7e
position dans la zone euro derrière le
Luxembourg derrière également la
Belgique l'Espagne ou la Grèce et en
revanche et bien la France faisait mieux
que le voisin allemand que l'Italie qui
frôlait et bien les 10% d'inflation sur
un an les pays les plus impactés de la
zone euro par la hausse des prix sont
notamment la Slovaquie et les pays
baltes en Lettonie et bien il y avait en
février sur un an 20% d'inflation quand
on se compare on se console quand on
regarde précisément et bien la hausse
des prix de l'alimentation en Europe
c'est à dire notamment et bien les
produits qui augmentent le plus c'est
bien on voit que là encore la France
n'est pas trop mal classé dans la zone
euro elle est huitièmes derrière Chypre
derrière l'Irlande ou l'Italie et elle
est devant l'Espagne le Portugal et
l'Allemagne outre-Rhin les produits
alimentaires augmentaient de plus de 20%
sur un an donc ça c'est pour le constat
ensuite si on regarde un peu comment les
gouvernements ont réagit est-ce que les
les mêmes causes produisent les mêmes
effets avec les mêmes mesures et bien
pas tout à fait les mesures sont
différentes en fonction des pays alors à
chaque fois c'est un cocktail de mesure
mais certaines stratégies sont à noter
selon les gouvernements en Europe par
exemple au Portugal c'était le choix
d'une TVA à taux zéro sur les produits
de première nécessité en Espagne les
ménages les plus modestes avaient le
droit avaient le droit à un chèque
pouvoir d'achat de 200 euros en Grèce il
y a eu un panier anti-inflation sur 51
produits en Allemagne un bouclier
tarifaire avec des gros moyens
200 milliards d'euros a été mis en place
en Italie par exemple c'était une baisse
de cotisation salariale qui a été
décidée par le gouvernement italien donc
des résultats différents et des
stratégies différentes également en
Allemagne bouclier tarière sur les prix
de l'énergie merci beaucoup Alexandre je
pose cette question parce que
Pascal est belle c'est cette comparaison
en France on a aussi fait le choix d'un
bouclier énergétique et pas d'un
bouclier alimentaire qu'est-ce que vous
en pensez de ça oui je pense que
vraiment le sujet alimentaire il est
jamais pris en compte par les
gouvernements c'est à dire que cette
question de manger qui est quand même
crucial né on n'a pas on met pas en
place de bouclier il doit y avoir un
chèque alimentaire on l'a abandonné
voilà c'était vraiment une promesse qui
date de février 2021 c'était même avant
la campagne et il est toujours pas mis
en place on a parlé de sécurité sociale
alimentaire et il y a des pays où on a
mis à zéro la TVA de produits
complètement essentiels même à la
Réunion qui est un département
d'outre-mer à 400 produits qui sont dans
un panier anti-inflation où les prix
n'augmentent pas en Suisse il y a des
produits de première nécessité comme le
lait par exemple ou c'est obligatoire
dans un magasin de trouver un niveau de
prix en France on n'a pas ça
c'est-à-dire qu'on a l'impression que on
remet à l'aide alimentaire finalement
cette question de ceux qui ne peuvent
pas se nourrir alors que il y a un
rapport qui est sorti qui dit qu'elle
est pas uniforme il y a des zones
évidemment les plus rurales on n'a pas
accès à cette année alimentaire et les
étudiants ces catastrophiques ils font
plus qu'un repas par jour aujourd'hui il
y a 40% de Français qui sont obligés
certains jours de prendre qu'un repas
par jour donc ce qui veut dire qu'on
mange moins bien et ça a un impact sur
la santé bien sûr c'est à dire que là
c'est le prix des légumes qui a le plus
augmenté 38% au mois de au mois de mars
donc évidemment on va pas manger des
fruits et légumes donc on mange comment
est-ce qu'on fait c'est à dire que on
lutte contre le gaspillage alimentaire
ce qui est une bonne chose mais on va
manger tous les jours la même chose et
donc il y a des foyers avec des familles
notamment les familles Monop mental où
il y a qu'un adulte ou on n'arrive pas à
manger suffisamment saute des petits
déjeuners on saute des repas essentiels
on a déjà eu ça en 2008 c'est à dire
qu'il y avait vraiment des familles qui
ne pouvaient plus de donner de petits
déjeuners ça s'est vu dans les écoles on
a été obligé de mettre en place des
petits déjeuners dans les dans les les
reps dans les zones d'éducation
propriétaire prioritaires et aujourd'hui
et bien on fait rien on attend que
que les gens se enfin se restreignent
eux-mêmes il y a pas forcément de la
débrouille c'est à dire que c'est on
comprend pas pourquoi on a aidé sur le
carburant on a mis 10 centimes de plus
alors que là on ne met rien du tout pour
aider les Français qui ont des budgets
énormes dont on a des énergies le
bouclier tarifaire sur l'électricité va
être prolongée jusqu'au début de l'année
prochaine annoncé Bruno Le Maire en
revanche celui sur le gaz va s'arrêter
dit-il en raison de la baisse du prix du
gaz ce qui est difficile à comprendre
aussi pour les gens je parle sous ou
votre contrôle d'économiste c'est que il
y a aussi une inflation qui dépend du
taux de change si vous prenez le cas de
la Suisse par exemple le meilleur
bouclier anti inflation en Suisse ça a
été le surenchérissement du franc suisse
le franc suisse est apprécié par rapport
au dollar donc les importations
notamment énergétiques se sont retrouvés
être meilleur marché que dans le reste
de l'Europe quand vous avez l'euro qui
s'affaiblit par rapport au dollars
finalement c'est double peine les prix
de l'énergie augmente mais en plus vous
la payer plus cher un mot là-dessus sur
le l'échange on est dans quelle
situation le l'euro est plutôt dans
plutôt en train de se renforcer face au
dollar c'est exactement l'euro est en
train de se réenfant de se renforcer
mais pour encore faut-il bien comprendre
les mécaniques par lesquels il le fait
il le fait notamment parce que face à
cette inflation qui s'est installée vous
avez désormais des relèvements de taux
d'intérêt qui sont beaucoup plus
importants et qui sont programmés être
beaucoup plus importants désormais de la
part de la Banque centrale européenne
relativement à la Réserve fédérale
américaine et donc vous avez plutôt une
tendance à la réappréciation du dollar
donc oui de l'euro pardon donc oui c'est
plutôt d'une bonne nouvelle du point de
vue de l'inflation mais du point de vue
de la dynamique de la demande c'est
beaucoup plus handicapant alors ça il
faut en parler la baisse de la
consommation enfin voilà c'est ce que
vous décriviez elle est et ça c'est
incroyable un moteur un moteur de
croissance donc est-ce que ça c'est
inquiétant dans les effets dominos de
l'inflation je trouve que là on est en
train de vivre une expérience naturelle
pour un économiste qui est tout à fait
exceptionnel qui s'appelle l'effet prix
vous regardez ça marche à plein vous
regardez vous mettez la coupe de
l'évolution des prix des produits
alimentaires et vous mettez la courbe du
volume consommé c'est on a été en cette
parfaite illustration de ce que quand
vous avez une augmentation du prix cela
se traduit inévitablement à un moment ou
un autre par une décrue de la demande
donc oui on est dans ce moment en ce
moment ou en fait on ce sont les
quantités qui s'ajuste sans qu'on ait
pensé véritablement à quoi correspondent
ces quantités combien se nourrir n'est
pas totalement indifférent des choix des
choix collectifs alors on a commencé à
l'aborder avec vous mais on va voir
quels sont les choix du gouvernement et
à Guillaume Daret après les retraites
évidemment ce sujet il est au cœur de
l'agenda politique oui et en même temps
quand on regarde l'interview du
président de la République au Parisien
on peut avoir le sentiment d'une réponse
un peu fataliste finalement mais plus
que du fatalisme ça représente plus une
forme de réalisme politique il faut
savoir que un ministre m'a raconté qu'en
privé Emmanuel Macron dit à ses
ministres les met en garde on leur
expliquant qu'il ne faut surtout pas
expliquer à tous les Français qu'ils
vont résoudre le problème de l'inflation
ce sont ces mots c'est un puissant fond
c'est ce qu'il dit à plusieurs des
membres de son gouvernement alors
pourquoi cette prudence Thomas parce que
plusieurs ministres estiment que
finalement il y a jamais de réponse
totalement satisfaisante sur la question
du pouvoir d'achat il nous faut juste
mettre des pansements sur les plaies en
essayant d'éviter qu'elle s'infecte
davantage me disait un autre membre du
gouvernement c'est pas très optimiste
tout ça mais parce qu'ils ont le
sentiment finalement que quoi qu'il
fasse les Français ne seront jamais
totalement satisfaits plusieurs exemples
on en parlait il y a quelques instants
par exemple le coup de pouce sur les
carburants et bien ce qui sera retenu me
disait justement un ministre qui est en
charge de ce secteur c'est davantage
quand la mesure finalement va prendre
fin que le coup de pouce qui aura été
donné pendant plusieurs semaines alors
que c'était finalement économiquement
coûteux écologique en discutable
également mais que c'est ça que les
Français vont retenir le exemple
justement sur l'alimentaire la grande
distribution par exemple c'est vrai
quand la ministre convoque par exemple
les patrons de la grande distribution
c'est surtout vu comme un coup de com la
plupart du temps il y a pas de lendemain
donc on a un premier ministre et un
président de une première ministre un
président de la République on le sent
qui essaie davantage finalement
aujourd'hui
d'éteindre les nouveaux départs de feu
mais l'incendie générale de l'inflation
ils peuvent pas y faire grand-chose et
puis à cela s'ajoute évidemment la
dimension budgétaire le gouvernement
cherche plutôt aujourd'hui à réduire les
dépenses mais c'est un argument qui est
devenu totalement
inodipolitiquement après le quoi qu'il
en coûte évidemment de la période du
conflit mais alors là où ça c'est encore
plus intéressant c'est que il y a une
sorte de constat de vous nous dites de
d'impuissance ou de Fatalis sauf que les
Français ils attendent beaucoup du
gouvernement ah ben davantage même que
sur les retraites on a vu que c'était la
première préoccupation des Français
comme le montre plusieurs études
d'opinion et notamment ce raisin en
sondage qui a été par l'institutif pour
le Journal du Dimanche sur lequel je me
suis penché cet après-midi pour 90% des
Français et bien la lutte contre
l'inflation ça doit être la priorité du
gouvernement et dans le même temps et
bien 80% de nos compatriotes jugent que
le gouvernement n'en fait pas assez sur
ce secteur et c'est bien la difficulté
que va devoir affronter le président de
la République qu'on voit depuis
plusieurs jours désormais vouloir
se finalement se frotter au quotidien
des préoccupations des Français le
problème c'est que sur ce quotidien des
préoccupations des Français et bien pour
l'instant ces derniers ne le jugent pas
à la hauteur il devrait recommencer il y
a une autre sortie demain prévu à
Vendôme dans la région Centre ça va
continuer
on verra jusqu'à quand il fait plus une
ou plusieurs sorties par par semaine il
y a plusieurs thèmes sur lesquels on va
rebondir peut-être d'abord le
constat je sais pas quel terme employé
parce qu'elle est belle d'impuissance
des gouvernements est-ce que dans une
économie globalisée ils ont vraiment une
marge de manœuvre pour pour tenter de la
casser l'inflation parce que ça pourrait
être objectif je pense que la question
de pouvoir bloquer ou d'avoir des prix
seuils comme il y a en Suisse sur des
produits complètement essentiels c'est à
dire que sur un régime alimentaire où on
sait que c'est le pain qui est consommé
en premier qui a des légumes qui a des
fruits on peut quand même se dire sur
ces produits là qu'on définit une liste
de produits essentiels etc et on bloque
la TVA et on bloque les prix avec le
chèque alimentaire on allait financer
pour une partie de la population au
moins en fait c'est au moins garantir
que tout le monde peut se nourrir quand
même c'est vraiment il y a pas de droit
à l'alimentation en France alors qu'il y
a bien un droit au logement c'est comme
si on jugeait que finalement se protéger
pour dormir était plus important que se
nourrir et c'est vrai que on se dit
quand même il y a un petit souci dans un
pays où en effet l'alimentation est au
cœur des relations des uns et des autres
aujourd'hui finalement les gens invitent
moins de gens chez eux et finalement
c'est ça qui nourrissait les relations
entre les uns et les autres le modèle
alimentaire est quand même à une place
très importante dans la vie de le
quotidien des Français et on n'a jamais
pris en charge ce sujet parce que il y a
le côté d'agriculture donc il faut
défendre la production il faut défendre
les agriculteurs et par contre protéger
les consommateurs on n'a jamais rien
fait en France votre avis là-dessus de
différent je suis toujours très méfiant
devant le risque d'un blocage des prix
un blocage des prix enfin on peut
multiplier les exemples dans l'histoire
où on voit que quand on bloque les prix
on bloque la production un moment ou un
autre et vous n'achalandez plus les
rayons comme vous pouvez ayez l'espérer
voir on a un exemple tout récent c'est
la Hongrie la Hongrie a bloqué ses prix
résultat vous avez des rayons qui
n'étaient plus approvisionnés vous
n'ayez plus des producteurs qui étaient
au rendez-vous et donc il a fallu lever
le blocage et prix 25% d'inflation qui
est qui survient d'un seul juste pour
bien comprendre ce qui s'est passé parce
que c'est très intéressant c'est quoi
c'était plus rentable pour les
producteurs de de fournir ce pays oui
tout à fait donc vous avez dire qu'on
est vraiment dans l'économie mondialisée
dont on parlait ou c'était
que la Suisse n'est pas dans le marché
unique européen notamment pour les
produits agricoles c'est-à-dire que là
vous avez le cas d'un pays à une petite
population avec un fort potentiel
agricole qui peut donc se permettre de
bloquer ce type de produit ce qui n'est
pas vrai d'autres pays qui sont intégrés
au marché européen il faut bien
reconnaître qu'à ses souvent les
producteurs ayant le choix d'exporter
par exemple vers jeudi n'importe quoi
les Pays-Bas ou l'Allemagne peuvent se
permettre de ne pas livrer la Hongrie
donc la problématique de blocage des
prix dans un marché unique et dans une
Union européenne elle est quand même
très difficile à gérer sinon sur l'autre
aspect sur lequel vous alertiez c'est à
dire c'est impuissance moi je crois que
quand même c'est l'impression qu'à la
population elle a l'impression de
gouvernement impuissant qui sont au fond
qui courent toujours derrière
l'inflation c'est l'inflation qui est là
en première et et ça encore une fois ça
mine aussi la crédibilité des
gouvernements vous savez que c'est un
problème et les populistes jouent bien
sur là-dessus en disant tous les
gouvernements entre guillemets d'experts
que vous avez élus ne sont pas capables
de gérer l'inflation nous on le fera
mieux
nous offre la transition puisque ce sera
le thème de notre second débat tout à
l'heure parce qu'on va s'intéresser au
vote rassemblement national en France
Guillaume juste un point qui est
intéressant c'est qu'on voit aussi dans
ces études d'opinion que l'inflation
ressentie par les Français et beaucoup
plus important que l'inflation réelle
dans les chiffres mais ça c'est un
argument évidemment qui porte pas pas
davantage que ce comparatif qu'on a vu
tout à l'heure ou quand les responsables
politiques expliquent aux Français que
finalement oui il y a une inflation mais
que c'est peut-être moins pire que chez
les voisins la plupart des Français
disent mais je n'habite pas chez mes
voisins j'habite en France donc ce sont
des arguments qui n'ont pas de vraies
valeurs politiques
sur votre observation par exemple je
m'interdis de dire que le pouvoir
d'achat des Français a progressé en 2022
et pourtant il a progressé mais c'est
inaudible et parce que cette
augmentation elle procède du fait que
oui les salaires n'ont pas progressé
comme l'inflation mais en revanche le
nombre d'employés lui a progressé et ça
on sent beaucoup moins on a une
impression ind qu'il n'y a pas de
progression du revenu et c'est vrai
parce que le salaire n'a pas progressé
hors prime n'a pas progressé comme
l'inflation mais en revanche on a
distribué du salaire
il y a donc il y a le collectif fait que
le pouvoir d'achat collectif a progressé
c'est exactement mais individuellement
il a pas progressé exactement et en fait
l'individuels plus important parce
qu'elle est belle il y a vraiment une
contrainte en France qui a pas ailleurs
on est le pays d'Europe derrière deux
pays où le poids du logement est le plus
important donc en 203 on avait déjà eu
ce constat d'un écart entre le ressenti
et le réel et on avait créé un pouvoir
d'achat effectif c'est à dire qu'on a
enlevait la dépense du logement
juste pour bien comprendre le poids du
logement dans le calcul du pouvoir
d'achat ou de l'inflation dans la
réalité de ce que vivent les gens ils
ont une dépense de logement qui est plus
forte qu'ailleurs et c'est surtout les
jeunes c'est surtout les familles tous
ceux qui aujourd'hui subissent la
réalité d'une inflation forte dans
l'alimentation donc c'est leur reste à
vivre qui finalement est plus réduit
qu'ailleurs
intérêt va accentuer cela encore par
exemple bien sûr et les DPE et toutes
les réglementations qui arrivent donc
les réglementations sur le fait que on
n'a pas le droit de vendre un logement
qui a pas été rénové sur le diagnostic
énergétique oui on va avoir des hausses
de prix sur le logement comme on aura
des hausses de prix sur la voiture
puisqu'on est obligé de passer à
l'électrique donc en effet il y a des
contraintes qui arrivent qui finalement
vont faire que ce sujet de ce qui reste
à vivre et de quoi manger parce qu'il
faut va se va se réduire et donc en
effet on est dans un pays où finalement
on a moins de possibilités de rogner sur
l'alimentation à cause du prix du
logement donc pour préciser on va avoir
des housses de coup sur les logements
mais les prix de l'immobilier risquent
de baisser ça l'effet de ciseaux
terrible c'est à dire que le vendre un
logement par exemple va vous coûter plus
cher vous allez devoir financer un
certain nombre d'études mais le revenu
que vous allez en tirer va diminuer je
voulais juste rappeler une chose que
vous avez dit tout à l'heure ouvrons
quand même les yeux en raison des
contraintes positives de la transition
climatique et écologique de toute façon
la hausse des prix d'un certain nombre
de produits et là pour rester c'est
évident donc et ça on le sait on sait
que ça coûte cher la transition
climatique et que souvent les
populations n'y sont pas préparées donc
il faut quand même le redire parce que
c'est une évidence c'est vrai que le
marché du bio par exemple il est
particulièrement secoué en ce moment
alors peut-être que c'est plus une
question pour pour Pascal mais il est
particulièrement secoué en ce moment par
le la première fois que ça diminue alors
que ça faisait des années que ça a été
c'était en croissance et en effet il y a
plusieurs effets il y a cette inflation
alimentaire qui fait que à moins payée
il y a le fait que l'offre finalement
les distributeurs vont en mettre
beaucoup moins dans les rayons et que
finalement les gens en trouvent en moins
on achète moins je vois vous poser une
question je rebondis sur un autre aspect
de votre Cody parce que ce que un
ministre prête comme moi Emmanuel Macron
attention à ne pas faire croire qu'on va
régler le sujet du pouvoir d'achat de
l'inflation c'est un puissant fond
est-ce que ces mesures là est-ce que
vous reprendriez cette expression à
votre
c'est exactement ce que vous évoquiez
c'est-à-dire que on voit quand on entre
dans un dispositif d'atténuation du choc
et c'est ce qui s'est passé l'année
dernière en termes d'atténuation du choc
de prix de l'énergie aucun autre pays de
la zone euro n'en a fait autant qu'en
France mais ils retiennent quand même
les ministres quand même les 15 %
d'augmentation oui le jour où ça revient
à la normale quoi l'effet de sortie on
sait très bien quand on entre dans ce
dispositif on sait jamais exactement
comment on en sort si ce n'est à ses
propres dépend donc c'est par exemple ce
que Total énergie a rajouté en plus à
l'aide de gouvernementale c'était
seulement en France
du monde il faut aussi rappeler donc
vous dites puissants font effectivement
parce que si vous n'attaquez pas le
problème c'est très bien identifié dans
le cas du logement en fait le problème
du logement c'est un question de niveau
de l'offre donc si vous si en plus vous
mettez en place des mesures qui viennent
réduire encore un petit peu plus l'offre
bien vous ne faites qu'accentuer le
problème donc si vous ne jouez que sur
un aspect où vous encouragez la demande
vous atténuer le signal prix vous vous
maintenez le même niveau de demande donc
le même déséquilibre entre l'offre et la
demande ce que vous devez arriver à
faire c'est pouvoir libérer l'offre là
où elle se trouve contrainte et où est
l'occasionne des oseries
sont fond dans lequel aussi le discours
politique d'Emmanuel Macron risque de se
noyer parce que l'argument central de
son discours politique aujourd'hui c'est
le plein emploi c'est de ramener les
gens au travail or quand même une
incitation forte à travailler c'est
consommer davantage c'est gagner plus
mais éventuellement consommer plus si
vous anticipez que de toute manière vous
ne pourrez pas consommer plus alors
pourquoi se remettre à travailler si je
puis dire et là on voit bien que le
gouvernement est inquiet là-dessus sur
ce baromètre parce que ça leur enlève un
argument pour convaincre les Français
d'adhérer à ce programme de plein emploi
d'autant qu'on le sait en France il y a
quand même ce problème si on compare à
d'autres pays européens de rémunération
les rémunérations dans un certain nombre
de catégories restent faibles et puis
vous avez des dispositifs tels que je
vais vous raconter une petite anecdote
personnelle ma belle famille est vie à
la frontière luxembourgeoise et les
aides pour aider les automobilistes
français étaient tels qu'on me racontait
la première fois depuis des décennies
qu'il voyait des automobiles
luxembourgeois traverser la frontière
pour venir faire le plein en France là
où tout le monde d'habitude va faire le
plein au Luxembourg oui effectivement
c'était l'effet inverse les supermarchés
aussi à la frontière belge ou les et les
Belges venaient en France acheter à
manger aussi parce que c'est vrai que
l'inflation était plus faible il y a 6
mois donc on est à la fois dans le
constat et puis dans le l'esquisse parce
que c'est pas simple évidemment de de
solutions je vous propose d'autres
chiffres le prix moyen des courses pour
un foyer français et l'augmentation
telle qu'elle s'exprime c'est 60
millions de consommateurs qui a réalisé
ces calculs plus
790 euros sur l'année ça c'est ce qui a
été évalué par nos confrères et par
l'association des forces des
consommateurs avec les produits qui
augmentent le plus
et la réaction des consommateurs
explications Lionel Mauguin qui
l'analyse justement au magazine 60
millions de consommateurs le rayon cale
plus augmenté dans les grandes surfaces
ce sont les viandes avec notamment une
flambée du prix du steak haché certaines
marques atteignent plus de 60% de hausse
on peut aussi parler du poulet du des
volailles en général
du Port également tout ça a augmenté de
manière considérable 10 20 30 40% depuis
un an et évidemment la consommation
baisse sur ces produits la viande le
poisson on a constaté il termine en
disant qu'un quart des Français avait
réduit tout simplement leur consommation
alimentaire depuis le début de l'année
c'est le concept vous faisiez tout à
l'heure je voudrais quand même qu'on
fasse un focus sur les les conséquences
en a commencé à l'aborder mais les
conséquences sur
la lutte contre le réchauffement
climatique les enjeux de d'urgence
climatique là on est vraiment dans deux
dans deux impératifs contradictoires
vous êtes d'accord avec ça donc et ça
pose la question du même du modèle
agricole qu'on doit promouvoir on en
parlera demain à faire un débat sur les
pesticides vous nous dites bon ben voilà
les conséquences du réchauffement
climatique c'est par exemple plus de
sécheresse c'est des rendements moindres
sur certaines productions est-ce que les
modèles d'agroécologie ou les modèles
bio peuvent permettre de fournir à une
population mondiale qui va augmenter
jusqu'à l'avenir enfin je vais pas vous
faire tout le toute la démonstration
mais là on efface à une contradiction
assez fondamentale on est face à une
contradiction sur tous si on réduit pas
les inégalités en fait ce qu'il faut
c'est qu'il faut qu'il n'acceptabilité
de ces mesures et en fait toute la
tension qu'on observe aujourd'hui c'est
bien ça c'est à dire que les plus
modestes toutes les mesures qui sont
mises en place une interprète comme on
va nous faire payer encore plus cher et
on reçoit moins enfin on reçoit pas plus
donc en fait il y a un vrai sujet sur
arriver à résoudre d'abord les les
questions d'inégalité sur la répartition
des revenus et surtout le fait que les
classes moyennes doivent gagner plus
pour en effet absorber ces contraintes
qu'on va avoir sur
en effet c'est pas sur l'alimentation
que c'est le plus crucial parce que sur
l'alimentation finalement baisser la
consommation de viande en fait il y a
des catégories qui pourraient le faire
un peu plus et ça ça permettra d'aller
dans le bon sens plutôt un effet positif
sur par contre sur le sujet de la
voiture c'est très très compliqué
c'est-à-dire que la mise en place des
zones faibles émission
ces catastrophique pour tous ceux qui
ont un vieux véhicule et qui doivent se
déplacer pour aller dans les centres
villes en fait pas forcément les moyens
d'acheter une voiture électrique
absolument les moyens de changer de
voiture et ils comprennent pas en fait
ce qu'il y a c'est qu'ils comprennent
pas pourquoi on leur ferait changer de
voiture alors que la leur fonctionne et
que évidemment pour eux en termes
économique ils ont intérêt à la faire
durer plus longtemps ils peuvent la
réparer eux-mêmes et un système D qui
peut se mettre en place sur le logement
on a évidemment la même chose si les
loyers augmentent et je pense que sur le
logement c'est surtout parce qu'on a un
modèle on est propriétaire et que c'est
des foyers qui sont propriétaires et qui
veulent un rendement important alors
qu'en Allemagne c'est un modèle ou ce
sont des institutions qui possèdent le
logement et finalement dans le c'est que
comme si on avait que du logement social
en fait en Allemagne donc c'est beaucoup
plus simple à gérer puisque les
investissements de rénovation se font
globalement par des gens qui sont plus
solides que des particuliers et des
particuliers veulent juste de la
rentabilité et sont pas capables de
payer la rénovation énergétique sur le
le logement effectivement avec cette
crainte qui est beaucoup de logements
qui ne soient plus sur le marché parce
que les propriétaires ne pourront pas
payer les les travaux de remise aux
normes
énergétiques où il intervenir oui je
voulais juste te dire que l'inflation et
la transition climatique ça va de paix
regarder par exemple aux États-Unis le
plan anti-inflation il est utilisé
officiellement pour accélérer la
transition climatique mais il est
utilisé beaucoup pour convaincre des
entreprises multinationales notamment
européennes aux États-Unis ce qui
fonctionne pas mal ce qui fonctionne
bien il y a déjà des projets de giga
Factory de batterie notamment qui sont
j'allais presque dire l'inflation
presque tout sauf économique et il y a
une base économique mais on en fait
aussi une utilisation politique mais
d'ailleurs sur les enjeux de
relocalisation qui sont nées de la crise
covid alors qui concernait par exemple
les médicaments mais mais qui peuvent se
poser aussi en matière alimentaire la
souveraineté alimentaire est-ce que
c'est pas contradict enfin la
globalisation elle s'explique aussi par
une recherche de prix bas tout à fait
est-ce que ça va nous coûter plus cher
exactement la précédente grande vague
d'inflation que l'on avait connue dans
les années 70 et début des années 80
elle a notamment été cassée par le
processus de globalisation c'était
précisément cette recherche de prix plus
bas à la grande à la grande importation
qui avait permis cette baisse donc là on
est en train mais sauf que la
globalisation elle est parfois absurde
ou même souvent absurde écologiquement
quand on produit des légumes en France
qu'on va aller faire des couper et mise
en boîte à l'autre bout de l'Europe pour
les faire revenir dans nos étalages
enfin bien entendu
on sent bien qu'il faut à la fois pour
des raisons de souveraineté parce qu'on
a vu combien cela coûtait de ne pas
avoir à sa disposition les respiratoires
artificiels les masques des produits
aussi banal on a bien vu ce que cela
coûtait et donc pour ces raisons de
souveraineté il faut faire revenir sur
le territoire de la production et tout
en faisant ensemble qu'elle soit
rentable parce que il y a pas parce
qu'elle est belle le sera mieux que moi
mais il y a plusieurs sondages qui
régulièrement sont faits sur combien
est-ce que vous seriez prêt payer en
plus pour acheter un produit français un
produit dont vous garantis qu'il est
produit sur le territoire on va monter à
15% dans les fêtes à mon avis si on
arrive à 5 % c'est à peu près le
déclaratif entre le déclaratif et on est
prêt à véritablement consacrer il y a un
écart qui me semblait assez important la
seule manière de pouvoir assurer la
combinaison entre cette aspiration à la
relocalisation et la maîtrise des prix
et bien c'est d'arriver à créer les
conditions de la compétitivité sur le
territoire c'est d'arriver à créer le
fait qu'on est un processus de
production qui soit beaucoup moins à
hurissant d'un point de vue
environnemental que celui que vous
décrivez et ça va prendre du temps c'est
une il n'y a pas de réponse rapide à
l'inflation ou alors il y a des réponses
comme celle des comme celles d'échec
mais qui est effectivement de l'ordre du
puissant fond l'inflation ça invite à
une réorganisation des processus de
production merci à tous d'avoir
participé à ce premier débat et à
bientôt sur public